[Musique]
sept affiches vantent les mérites d'un
jouet elle nous avait frappés
elle a été le point de départ de cette
émission images sommaire d'une certaine
idée du mal à défaut d'une certaine idée
de l'homme visage buriné balafré corps
toujours prêts à l'action voilà l'homme
mitraillette grenade et bazooka sont le
prolongement naturel de sa main est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression tout de
même de provoquer à la violence je ne
pense pas que je provoque la violence
je pense que actionne jour permet à
l'enfant d'exprimer un certain un
certain désir de de combat qu'il y a en
lui
chez les garçons je pense qu'il ya une
une virilité naissante qui fait que ce
garçon a besoin de de combattre je crois
que l'important c'est de donner à
l'enfant une base de concepts que ce
soit un concept militaire que souhaite
un concept d' aventure que soit un
concept de sportifs l'important c'est
que l'enfant est un tremplin
d'expression de sa personnalité du monde
qu'il cherche à découvrir
est ce ce monde que nous cherchons à
mettre à sa portée par l'intermédiaire
de ce personnage c'est un petit peu la
musculature modèle que chaque garçon de
12 ou 13 ans voudrait avoir pâti sera un
peu plus vieux
les enfants est ce que vous aimeriez
ressembler à axione jours
oui oui oui mais c'est pas la peine
pourquoi pas valable ça ne fait rien
c'est bien ça me ferait peur aux filles
ont pu extraire mais vous aimez bien
aimé bien ressembler actionne jour si
vous avez un choix à faire
c'est savuth waziers c'est à dire être
un homme d'action
vous préférez être des garçons ou les
préférés des filles
pensez vous que les petits garçons par
exemple soit plus violente que les
petites filles
je ne le pense pas je le sais et quand
je dis je le sais c'est pas seulement
par mais propose expérience encore que
j'en aie fatih m'est arrivé de faire des
observations sur des tas de sable et de
noter absolument scientifiquement
combien de fois il y avait un des
marmots là qui attaquer pour reprendre
et jouer de l'autre comme j'aurais
observer des fourmis ou des éperviers où
des chars français
et bien c'est un 8 à 10 fois plus
souvent les garçons l'histoire les jeux
par exemple montre simplement dans notre
beau pays de douze france que depuis le
moyen âge depuis qu'on a des archives
par exemple de folklore les batailles
rangées entre garçons avec les parents
qui applaudissait par derrière et les
batailles qui faisait des morts chaque
année n'est ce pas étaient organisées
dans les villages dans toutes les
régions de france et qu'ils ont toujours
joué et qui avec des épées de bois qui
avec des frondes et les frondes c'était
quand même extrêmement dangereux jusqu'à
ce que des ordonnances de police
n'arrête à cause des morts justement
mais il ya toujours eu des jeux violent
très violent chez les petits garçons
pourquoi vous pouvez faire des garçons
en moi parce que je vois
parce qu'on est comme ça ouais
qu'est ce que tu penses des gars au sens
général quant au canton va tranquille
suis comme du petit chien
oui il ya des choses que tu reproches
aux garçons comment tu les trouves
trémie sont les filles sont basés à face
et tout devenait bagarreur et puis
quelle qualité quel défaut le retrouver
bon bah le site soit pas au nom ça c'est
pas voir son nom dracula enfin je me
dise où on a fait la moyenne de la
classe les les garçons dont des
meilleures notes que celle des filles
étaient aussi ils font toujours protégé
par les maîtresses et les chouchous les
filles ont comparé exemple la cour après
ils font que de créer bien sûr si vous
les embêter owen a inscrit hier ils
viennent chercher des fois puis après
ils vont dire qu on les embête de guerre
voilà maîtresses falloir dire collet on
les embête massification du bref avant
d'effacer pour le gazole et qu'il se
soit passé quoi pour reprendre les fils
par tous les pays non monsieur t
même s'ils ne jouent qu'un saut ouais si
on met à nu vous avez vu ce petit garçon
il en sait pas un jouet de fist a joué
deux garçons qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
il est conforme c'est-à-dire au modèle
qui est vécu chez lui il entend dire ça
chez lui alors il leur vie il est pompée
il est poussé pour les filles les
poupées aussi c'est pour les filles
issues
qu'est ce qu'ils aiment bien julien tu
n'y ai joué à la poupée au regard non
pas du tout je proteste un petit peu
contre ce nouveau conformisme qui
consisterait à refuser de donner des
poupées aux filles et de leur donner que
des objets qu'ils participeraient à la
libération féminine
c'est finalement une nouvelle idéologie
et récupérer le jouer afin d' une
nouvelle idéologie disant ongles être
une autre pourquoi on combattre une
autre autrefois le jouer avec comme but
de renforcer l'idéologie dominante qui
était la femme au foyer derrière ses
casseroles et s'occupant des enfants
alors maintenant une nouvelle idéologie
apparaît et on réquisitionne le jouet ou
le livre pour défendre cette idéologie
c'est tout ce qu'il faut faire c'est pas
s'en mêler pour fait même qu'à ça
ressemble plus aux chais pas c'est plus
naturel ou jamais de l'autre nous un peu
cette poupée mannequin
comment est née cette poupée mannequin
d'entre nous savent banhart
oui on dire une dame didon ça ressemble
beaucoup à une poupée avant les pluies
et se ressemblaient à des bébés à des
poupons et ça ça ressemble à quoi
toul un peu vers la caméra qu'on voit et
c'est vraiment une jeune femme ça et
l'homme qu'est ce que ça doit être comme
en ce qu'elle ken qualité ça doit avoir
un ingénieux le quai ce convoyeur
travailleurs et la femme ne doit pas
travailler
c'est visible pour le ménage village les
uns des cours à vay vous trouvez ça bien
c'est raisonnable
est-ce que tu une idée de ce que tu veux
faire dans la vie plus tard je suis
couturière
parce que je ne veux pas t'entendre et
si tu avais été un garçon qui aurait
voulu faire quel métier au joker docteur
aussi et pourquoi tu penses que tu peux
pas être docteur en étant pires est ce
que tu sais ce que tu veux faire plus
tard dans la vie comme métier
d'agricultrice puéricultrice
cet intérêt si tu avais été un garçon
qu'est ce que tu aurais aimé faire comme
métier
inspecteur inspecteurs de quoi police
l'inspecteur de police et tu penses que
tu veux pas être inspectrice de police
en civil non pourquoi ce existe pas ça
existe pas te croire richard ya des fans
la police
oui c'était secrétaire je veux être faux
policiers
quand green power ois vétérinaire waouh
négociant en bestiaux négociant en
bestiaux négociant en bestiaux pourquoi
ça gagne beaucoup
ah ouais non c'est important pour vous
l'argent non non non c'est saison et
pour le plaisir de faire le métier qui
nous inspire
si j'étais une fille qui si vous aviez
été défi qu'est ce que vous auriez fait
comme métier aux majorettes et plus on
est hyper culte rice qu'est ce que tu
veux faire plus tard toi moi faudra les
dans l'école polytechnique
oui mais c'est encore sur andrew et ben
je me détends sur ce quoi alors j'aime
pas travailler soit je travaillais alors
ça sera ça sera ta femme qui fera dire
le travail ménager ou non parce que je
crois qu'elle leur a fait pendant une
journée une journée quand vous serez
grande on serait adultes que vous aurez
un métier ou par métier je ne sais pas
qu'est ce que vous ferez du matin au
soir
qui veut répondre à cette question la
réponse qu'on va par contre tu es
déjeuner au lit quand apporte un petit
déjeuner au lit ou et toute la portera
ton petit-déjeuner au lit premier enfant
mari après abba freine pas aller
travailler
oui mais vraiment travail de couleur
procès muriel m'occuper des riasq du le
derrière
alors qu'ils font le ménage mais chez
pas si mon mari fait pitié peu haché
nuit puis si l'offre et sera même des
ménages alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez les autres là estelle jeu la même
opinion que l'âne
non juste jeu le matin je me lèverai tôt
pour partir à mon travail puis en
rentrant je m'occuperai de la maison
ouais et doit les abete dégénéré après
il partira au travail oui bien
après ce retrait pourrait couper mes
chansons enfin quant à leur tour porté
qu'un coup tu l'auras compris une
journée de plus tard quand tu seras dans
quand tu seras adultes
qu'est ce que tu fais dès le matin je
peux la haye après je peux pas j'ai volé
oui je m'appuyais oui je descends fouet
et après je le crois pas
oui on va valider chez oui et puis je
vais apprendre à sortir
oui et les soins concurrentes est-ce que
tu rentres à d'abord oui et quand tu
rentres qu'est ce que tu fais là une
approche même les mains ouais après je
mange
oui après dun après jamais trompé lama
et après je regarde la télé tu m'as dit
que tu voulais être quoi dans la vie
qu'à faire quel métier d'infirmière bon
alors tu auras ton travail mais avant
ton travail qu'est ce que tu feras oui
il dit
[Musique]
du pur en train de ton travail qu'est ce
que tu feras les courses et après je
crois à blanchet et après après le dîner
vaisselle ac oui c'est bien c'est bien
[Musique]